al menos 20 de las víctimas del
naufragio de la semana pasada eran de la
ciudad de burlan walla tres de ellas
vivían en esta calle amirmalik es primo
de una de las víctimas
el 9 de junio embarcó hacia Italia pocos
días después ocurrió este accidente
por el momento no sabemos oficialmente
si Murió o sobrevivió Esta es la última
nota de voz que le dejó muy sin
[Música]
esta nota de voz el 9 de junio
una vez que llegó a Libia Los
contrabandistas le quitaron el teléfono
no tuvimos más remedio que confiar en el
contrabandista para ponernos en contacto
con él así nos enteramos de que no iba a
viajar a Europa en avión sino
ilegalmente en barco mochin nos dijo
estoy Atrapado No tengo más remedio que
seguirles
6.400 euros fue la cantidad que moschin
pagó a sus contrabandistas para llegar a
Europa sus padres tuvieron que vender su
casa para pagar el viaje unos metros más
abajo en la misma calle otra familia
llora un pariente desaparecido en el
naufragio moniza no tiene noticias de su
hijo admir
padre de una niña de un año
mi hijo me hizo esta pregunta antes de
irse dime mamá Cómo puedo sobrevivir
aquí los pañales son muy caros la leche
es cara no tengo dinero para alimentar a
mis hijos y luego están las facturas de
Electricidad y gas en todas las familias
los jóvenes están desesperados suplican
a sus padres que vendan la casa para
poder irse a trabajar al extranjero
en Pakistán hay cada vez más gente
planteándose migrar la inflación de los
últimos años y la crisis política ha
asumido a gran parte de la población en
la desesperación